I had a summer where I play basketball
when I was like 10 or 11 years old
yeah come playing and I don't score at
one point the entire summer really not
one you can blow past people who have
decades more experience and talent and
skill than you because you're just
willing to work harder than their a lot
of people and I'm just not one of them
believe that you should live for the now
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up believe nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee and
sip on today's message be a long-term
thinker over to you Kobe Bryant also if
you want to know what Kobe Bryant and
others have to say about excellence
check out my to 54 block excellent
series where every day for the next 254
days I will send you a morning video for
free highlighting excellence in the
black community the link to join is in
the description below there are certain
things that we want to get to but we
have to pace those out because we have
to have absolute focus you start with
when you want your game to be will we
make your game most unstoppable or hard
to deal with
[Music]
I had a summer where I played basketball
when I was like 10 or 11 years old and a
very prominent some really good
Philadelphia called the Sunny Hill beat
my father played my uncle played never
liked all-time great stuff and Wilt
Chamberlain played in league you know
another Pro Monroe playing league and
here I come playing and I don't score
one point the entire summer
really not one how old were you 11 10 11
you're playing against other 10 11
year-old start you need to score once
not one were you in the game I was in
again how'd you not score because that
was terrible really yeah that had on
every years old you were that awful I
mean I you know and I had these big knee
pads on because I'm growing weak fast I
have socks all the way up here and I had
like the pod tops pity yeah like skinny
as hell and I scored not a free throw
not a nothing not a lucky shot not a
breakaway layup zero points is that when
you think the mentality of hard work
started to come in for you at that age
when you failed so miserably I guess
that's somewhere I think that's when the
idea of understanding a long-term view
became important because I wasn't gonna
catch these kids in a week I wasn't
gonna catch him in a year right so
that's we I said down it's okay this is
gonna take some father all right we'd
all want to work on first
all right shooting all right let's knock
this out let's focus on this half a year
six months do nothing but shoot right
after that
all right creating your own shot and you
focused so you start I started creating
a menu of things when I came back the
next summer I was a little bit better
right it made me be like I've got my
jump shot from 15 of God yeah I got my
15 I got my three-point shot like just
open shots not miss open shots right be
able to shoot it with speed because
those kids are so much more athletic
yeah and then the next time I came back
as a little better the summer came back
was a little bit I scored yeah it wasn't
much but I scored 12 13 12 13 and then
14 came around back half of 13 14 years
old and then I was just killing everyone
and it happened in two years and I
wasn't expecting to happen in two years
but it did because what I had to do was
work on the basics and the fundamentals
while they relied on athleticism
and their natural ability and because I
stick to the fundamentals it just caught
up to them and then my body you know my
knees stopped hurting I grew into my
frame and and then your athleticism once
you have the fundamentals actly
the hard work the mindset and you tack
on the 11 did it was game Wow
so from 13 you're good average still
that was good that was good about about
like the end of my 30 like right when I
was turning 14 I became best clear in
the state a 14 or 14 so I'm from 12 to
14 you went from scoring zero to being
the best in the state of all ages yep
but it's simple like if you do the math
on this right like if you if you're
thinking about how often kids are
playing mmm all right I'll tell it some
on to my daughter and my daughter's team
as well that I coach it's a simple thing
of math does you want to be a great
player if you play every single day 2-3
hours every single day we're course of a
year how much Ben are you getting most
kids will play maybe you know an hour
and a half two days a week right it's
not gonna get it done get it done right
so if you're obsessive obsessive
obsessively training to three hours
every single day over a year over two
years
dirty celery make quantum leaps man I
don't consider myself to be one of the
world's greatest public speakers yet but
my YouTube channel has exploded past
people who I think are way more talented
than me because I'm pumping out way more
content than they are four and a half
years ago I had seven thousand
subscribers on my channel four and a
half years ago I had seven thousand
subscribers four and a half years later
by doing three videos every single day
for four and a half years three videos a
day now we're up to 1.7 million from
7,000 to 1.7 million i blown past people
who i think are way more talented than
me because i did 3 videos every single
day and this isn't just a youtube thing
i'm applying it to instagram now just to
prove to myself that I could do it again
cuz I love the climb and the build so
much I started the year on Instagram
with 6,000 followers and wasn't taking
it seriously
somewhere mid this year mid 2018 I
decided I'm gonna take this more
seriously
I started posting more frequently I'm
doing six posts a day right now we're
doing three videos a day three posts a
day picture post I'm going live usually
at least once a day we're doing stories
three to eight to 20 times a day
6,000 followers at begin of the year
we're gonna end the year close to a
hundred thousand followers from six
thousand to a hundred passing people who
are thinking more talented than me along
the way because I'm putting in the work
this is the way for you to blow past
people who have more natural talent than
you a lot of people complain and they
sit on the sidelines to say well that
person is just so good I'm never gonna
win you can outwork them you can always
outwork them and that's why it's so
important that you do the thing that you
love because they're willing to put in
the work you're willing to put in the
hours and you can you can blow past
people who have decades more experience
and talent and skill than you because
you're just willing to work harder than
they are so closer to the beginning of
my YouTube journey I joined an agency
I've been agent Steve and he represents
me on a whole bunch of deals book deals
speaking gigs that kind of stuff and
when I first joined I almost didn't get
in I almost didn't get in he told me I
wasn't good enough it's like I usually
deal with people who are a lot more
polished than you Evan I'm dealing
people who have been on CNN and Fox and
ABC and they had a lot of TV experience
and you're just kind of getting started
but you know the thing I like about you
is I love your believe message we have
to work with people to develop a message
and I just like what your message is so
I'm gonna take a flier on you so he took
a shot I got my shot you know you get
your one shot one opportunity right what
are you gonna do and he gave me an
assignment you said Evan here's what I
need you to do here's your first video
you need to make a video that tells your
foundation story you got to tell me why
you do what you do tell me the pain you
went through tell me why you're here
what is that story and this should be 15
to 20 minutes great
right away I made that video he gave me
feedback so over lunch time I made it
again he gave me feedback over dinner
time I did it again and so for three
times a day I was making the same video
15 to 20 minutes three times a day to
get better I took his feedback and I did
it again
I took his feedback and I did it again I
ended up making that video 30 to 40
times for
something that was passable and within a
couple months of applying that strategy
of taking feedback improving it getting
better making multiple videos a day
getting better feedback getting better I
quickly went from being the worst at the
agency to being the best practice I went
from the guy who almost didn't get in
because I had such little experience and
I don't consider myself talented at this
go back on her channel and watch the
videos I am NOT naturally gifted at
doing this stuff
it took me 350 videos before I wasn't
absolutely embarrassed by my own content
I could not watch my content back 700
something before I got inspired myself
that I watched my own videos I can't
okay it's happening I'm starting to get
good this is great
700 videos I went from being the worst
to being the one that they were showing
the other people at the agency to say
you should copy whatever is doing look
at look at what he's up to you should be
doing that too on your YouTube channel
now what was the difference the
difference was I was just putting in
more work the difference was I was
willing to do three videos a day where
they were having a hard time to find
time for one video week and so somebody
has more talent than you but they're
only working one day a week hustling to
get better and you're doing it three
times a day you're gonna catch up and
you're gonna pass them and you're gonna
be unstoppable you're gonna build crazy
momentum that's been the secret for me
forever not naturally gifted any of this
stuff I applied it to YouTube I'm gonna
bring it to Instagram too I'm gonna post
six times a day and do stories 3 to 20
times a day and go live every day of the
week for 4 years I'm gonna have 1.6
million followers the exact same way and
you can too if you willing to work so
I'm gonna give you a three step process
to follow to destroy the people who are
way ahead of you and way more talented
than you because you're willing to work
here it is step number one identify
where you want to win what's the thing
that you want to win it pick the thing
you can't be world-class at everything
pick the thing that you want to be
world-class add that you want to win
maybe it's YouTube
maybe it's Instagram maybe it's selling
sneakers new beats Facebook ads like
what is the thing that you want to be
world
class at identify write it down step
number two schedule for success if you
want to be great at that thing you need
to make time in your calendar to
practice your actions have to map to
your ambitions you say you want to be
world-class at this amazing let me look
at your calendar and see how much time
you're spending daily on that thing you
have to spend time daily on that thing
you have to find time you have to make
the time if this is important to you if
you're only spending time once a week
doing it trying to get better then
you'll have somebody less talented than
you pass you by because they're willing
to do it three times a day your actions
have to map to your ambitions open up
your calendar and create time every
single day to practice getting better at
the skill that you want to be
world-class at it needs to be in your
calendar it needs to get done you need
to practice every single day and then
step number three is flip your patience
and impatience I think you need to have
both patience and impatience just people
have it in the wrong spots I think
people are really impatient with the
results like why am I not getting
results why am I not getting better how
come when people aren't like anymore how
come I'm not selling more stuff you're
really impatient what the results ASAP
but you're patient with yourself this is
the problem people are too patient with
themselves like well what work did you
put in to get there well I did something
on it last week it's not enough you need
to flip it you need to be patient with
the results the results will come
patient that took me four years right is
it possible to get there sooner sure if
you had more talent than I did you can
you can get there sooner but it took
four years to get there but I was
impatient with myself you need to be
impatient with yourself patient with the
results impatient with yourself like
what did you do today what did you do
today to get closer to your goals what
did you do what did you work on and so I
think people have a flipped stopped
being so patient with yourself stop
demanding instant results and instead be
impatient with you job demand effort
from yourself every day and if you do
that
you're a little bit patient with the
results they'll come I promise
now I've got a really special bonus clip
for you but before that question of the
day I want to know what will you commit
to practicing daily so you can become
world-class at let me know put in the
comments below
do something you're very passionate
about and don't try to chase what is
kind of the hot passion of the day I
think we actually saw this I think you
see it all over the place in many
different context but I think we saw it
in the internet world quite a bit where
you know it's sort of peak of the sort
of internet you know mania and say 1999
you found people who were you know very
passion or something they kind of left
that job and decided I'm gonna you know
do something in the internet because
it's you know it was almost like the you
know the 18-49 Gold Rush in a way I mean
you find that people if you go back and
study the history of the 18-49 Gold Rush
you find that you know at that time
everybody who was in was within the
shouting distance of California was you
know they might have been a doctor but
they quit being a doctor and they
started panning for gold and that that
almost never works and even if it does
work you know according to some metric
financial success or whatever it might
be I suspect it leaves you ultimately
unsatisfied so you really need to be
very clear with yourself and I think one
of the best ways to do that is this
notion of projecting yourself forward to
age 80 looking back on your life and
trying to make sure you've minimized the
number of regrets you have that works
for that works for career decisions it
works for family decisions you know do
you want I have a 14 month old son and
it's very easy for me to if I think
about myself when I'm 80 I know I want
to watch that little guy grow up and so
it's I don't want to be 80 and think
shoot you know I missed that whole thing
and I don't have the kind of
relationship with my son that I wished I
had and so on and so on
I guess another thing that I would
recommend to people is that they always
take a long term point of view and I
think this is something about which
there's a lot of controversy you know
there's a there's a you know something a
lot of people and I'm just not one of
them believe that you should live for
the
now I think what should do is you think
about the the great expanse of time
ahead of you and try to make sure that
you're planning for that in a way that's
going to leave you ultimately satisfied
so this is just my this is the way it
works for me and I mean this is
everybody needs to find that for
themself so there are a lot of paths to
satisfaction and you need to find one
that works works for you if you want
more Cobie check out the top ten rules
video I made on him the link is right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there there's a choice we have to make
as people as individuals so if you want
to be great at something
[Music]